في مثل بيقولوا همم الدبور زن على خراب
عشه هذا تحديدا اللي صاير مع مجرم هارب من
العداله اسمه كريستوفر سبورتنج في ولايه
جورجيا الامريكيه واللي ممكن نسميه يعني
بكل كده اريحيه اريد ان نسميه المجرم
الاحمر لانه مكتب الشرطه في المقاطعه اللي
ساكن فيها نشر على فيسبوك لا احد دوريه
بينشروها وهي عباره عن اهم 10 مطلوبين
لشهر نوفمبر علشان تساعدهم الناس في القبض
عليهم او الابلاغ بمعلومات عنهم الاخ زكي
كريستوفر يبدو انه الغرور اخذوه ازعاج كيف
هو مو من اهم او اكثر 10 مطلوبين يعني مش
هذا الكلام يعني فجاء معلق على البوست كتب
لهم طب وانا انه
باقول لكم يعني
هبل الحماقه قامت الشرطه ما كذبت خبر وردت
عليه على طول قالت له معك حق في مذكرتين
قبض بحقك واحنا في الطريق اللي عندك وفعلا
وصلوا له وجبدوا عليه
حيث الشرطه نشرت سكرين شوت من البوس
والكومنت وفهمت الناس انه لائحه المطلوبين
الاهم مو معناها انهم الوحيدين لكن هدول
الاخضر او اللي عليهم تهم اكثر لكن مو
معنى هذا ابدا انه باقي المطلوبين ما
بندور عليهم وعلى فكره شكروا كريستوفر
كمان انه ساعدهم يقبضوا عليه ونبهوا كمان
الناس انه اللي مو عارف لو في امر بالقبض
عليه او لا يتفضل يرن علينا او يبعث لنا
ايميل يعني روحي ورط نفسه
[موسيقى]